[Music]
all right
hi I'm Andreas I'm in the enterprise
customer intelligence org at Capital One
we are a horizontal platform team we
create platforms to process data from
the entire enterprise and compute
insights and again deliver them to
internal customers all across the
company as few people from my team are
here you've maybe seen some of us with a
Capital One t-shirts walking around the
sessions there's some hands back there
I'm wearing my Capital One Coda's
t-shirt today that's our volunteer work
where we teach middle school kids coding
up to the point where they write their
own first mobile app which is really fun
so I'm gonna be talking about stream
processing design parents basically how
we think about streaming and how we use
that to deliver an exceptional
personalization experience to our
customers at Capital One so let's start
from the customer because that's what we
care about let's say you're a customer
here on the left and you're clicking
around on our web page and you're
looking for some specific information
and you find
oops I'm back on the home page what
happened I'm kind of moving around in
circles let me just call and and see if
I can some help and then on the right we
have our support representative who's
gonna say yeah hey customer please tell
me what you were trying to do because I
have no idea what you just did
even though the customer was just
interacting with us as a company through
our webpage and then the representative
finds out yeah this is kind of a special
case let me connect you to my colleague
here and that colleague says excuse me
but can we just rewind and start from
the beginning and just tell me exactly
what you're trying to do and at this
point the customers probably mildly
irritated and I feel for our
representative on the right here because
he's trying to make the customer happy
and through no fault of his own the
customer is already a little bit unhappy
at this point and so maybe I can ask for
show of hands who's never had a customer
service experience like that it's pretty
common right and as engineers who has
ever thought that in the age of
networked computers it doesn't need to
be that way
yeah and and you're right and and we
think so too which is why we built these
platforms so I'll give you a very simple
example to start with which is we have
some interaction coming from the
customer and we add some additional
information and then from here we can
say hey this is information available to
you and this is how we collect
information we we have basically a rest
server which is called our collector
then we persist the data into Kafka from
where we can send it in two different
directions and at the top right from
Kafka you see the enricher and this is a
stateless process where we add some
additional information and then we have
sdp which is the streaming data platform
which is a company-wide again horizontal
platform where we publish the data for
real-time streaming consumers and we
also persist the data into data
warehouses you can see snowflake and
redshift here in the picture so that
analysts can consume this data so let's
see you what what what does an energy
look like it's a stateless process it's
the simplest thing you can do with
scalable frameworks like spark streaming
flaying kafka streams or you just send a
bunch of jars into a cluster they don't
need to know about each other because
they will take each individual piece of
data do some computation with it and
then output whatever the result was so
this is gonna be my my symbol for a
compute node is kind of the steering
machine looking thing that has an input
stream and some output and you can do
some simple mappings like you can remove
sensitive information to protect your
customers privacy
you can filter things that are relevant
to you and not worry about having to
consume everything on your consumer end
and like we just discussed you can
enrich I'm not going to be talking about
any programming if you're interested in
that if you have less experience with
streaming frameworks you can take a look
at this link down here bitly slash
simple transformations
I simply cloned an example of a flink
job and added some very simple examples
for you to look at when I'm doing some
maps and filters and some unions but
take note this is the extent of what you
can do with stateless job as soon as you
want to do any joins they will have to
become windowed because you have an
infinite data set in a stream and if you
do and you reduce then of course you
also need to store the intermediate
result so it becomes stateful again and
then we have to think a little bit
harder oh and I want to show you on the
right-hand side of the screen I'm gonna
be using some qualitative measures here
to talk about how we think about the
performance of these approaches and here
in this case is going to be our baseline
so we're going to say this is
low-latency we do everything one by one
and our Throop is gonna be pretty high
and we don't need to store anything so
we have very little memory usage so
let's let's go to a more interesting
example where we actually want to store
a few of the most recent interactions
for our customer so that then our
representative can say something like oh
yeah I see what you're doing let me help
you out and guide you along the next
step what's more is this is this is the
example where a customer decided to call
what we can also do is we can offer a
personalized assistant to every customer
because we recomputing this for everyone
so why not so here again we can store
the interactions and do something with
that and we can tell the customer here
are some options I think you're
interested in this kind of stuff check
it out and then the customer has has
very easy
a path to reach the information that
they're looking for and so very simple
way to do that in a stream processor is
using internal state which means that
within the processor you're going to use
a lot of memory which you can see on the
right to stack up all those interactions
from recent times you want to sort them
maybe by a customer so they all kind of
grouped together and grouping things
together will require shuffling them
through the network in your cluster so
it's gonna be some network use which is
going to push your latency up and some
frameworks give you a really cool a
possibility to actually query the
internal state so you can talk to an
endpoint in your computer cluster and
say hey what's the state right now which
is really nice so you're the processor
can kind of serve as your as your key
value database at the same time the
other way to deal with this and perhaps
try to avoid shuffling your data across
the network between your computer notes
is use an external state if you are
looking for high performance you can use
something like Redis or rocks DB we're
going to keep the memory usage low which
makes it I'm sorry which makes it cost
effective whoo I went all the way here
we go which makes it more cost-effective
on your compute cluster and you don't
have to shuffle but you can just push
into your into your state here so you
saw already in the in the diagram where
you had a Kafka cluster in the middle as
a message broker another way to avoid
shuffling between your computer notes is
to try sending the data where it belongs
all to the same spot and the way you can
do that is producing it into Kafka with
a key that is relevant to your
computation that you want to do then
they will already end up on the same
nodes because one Kafka partition
translates to one task in your processor
and then you can maybe do some reduction
on the data already before you push it
into an external stage
it so then you reduce the the network
load because you already reduced down
the data somewhat but you have to take
into account that the tasks can be
rescheduled in case of failure or just
because your scheduler decided to do
that if you have back pressure or
something like that so you cannot rely
on things that belong together always
being in the same place which is why I'm
showing you a design here with an
external state which will be the target
where everything comes back together if
it has been separated and so for for
thinking about Kafka it depends on your
business problem maybe you have a small
trickle of data for a lot of different
streams in which case for example
business workflows in which case you
have a picture like here on the top we
have a kind of a rainbow of different
things that are happening on your Kafka
cluster and in this case if you have a
ton of partitions in each topic then any
failure in Kafka will trigger a long
pause to reelect leaders for your
partitions so it's probably a good idea
for this kind of applications to have
very few partitions for each topic we
have a the opposite situation where we
have one big stream of a lot of data and
in that case we have to think about
downstream what happens downstream in
our compute cluster where we want to be
able to scale up and the number of
partitions gives a number of tasks as I
just mentioned and so your concurrency
is given by the number of topic
partitions in Kafka so you probably want
to use a somewhat higher number of
partitions which is kind of the the
image on the lot on the bottom so you
still have a lot of partitions but only
one topic so now working around failure
requires recovering from failure and in
a stateful task that means that when you
just crash your in-memory state is gone
and you might have a completely new
instance we work a lot of
aw yes so you have to rebuilt the state
or you can reload it and that's why
checkpointing exists all frameworks have
some sort of check pointing
functionality and again this takes time
in order to recover from this so your
latency might be inconsistent and so
this kind of a topic where we as
engineers think about this and we were
kind of aware of this but we need to
communicate it to our data consumers in
our case in-house and to everybody who's
designing the product to make sure that
everybody can plan around these short
pauses and I've shown here in the green
arrows that maybe at first we have some
regular output at a regular interval and
then we're kind of shrugging sorry
nothing right now and then we have a
bunch of output and we catch up and then
we're back to normal
right so in this case if we have a bot
that's giving our customer some useful
cool information we need to be able to
have some heuristics or some default as
you've seen this morning in the talk
from the Netflix recommendation system
they always have fall backs for for what
they recommend and in this case it's the
same thing it's a general general
challenge of course so then when you
think about failure torrents you also
have to think about at least once
processing versus exactly ones
processing so when you fail you might
have just produced a bunch of outputs
you reload your check point that reads
your state but the state is from several
outputs ago so you start processing and
churning away and you create outputs
again and now you have a few outputs
that you created twice and that's at
least once processing a works finest
resilient you have at least produced
some output you haven't lost anything
but your consumer needs to be prepared
so if your consumers not prepared and
you need to do exactly once processing
and that's pretty challenging because
you would add either have to checkpoint
after each output so that when you roll
back
you don't replay anything that you just
did or you have to batch your outputs
together and only when you produce a
bunch of outputs you checkpoint then
exactly then in that case you're not
going to have low latency right so if
you're looking for real-time
applications that's not the way to go if
you check finding all the time you're
not going to have a lot of capacity so
it's maybe not the best idea what's
better is to use idempotent designs and
that's also been mentioned today so I
wanted to just make that super obvious
that just means we have an ID ID on on
every message or every item of data and
then we can issue that into our output
and then on the receivers end we don't
say hey I have this bank transaction
some money went off my bank account and
then the same transaction happen again
no we don't want that right we don't
want to lose the money twice we have
transaction number one two three four
five and then one two three four five
comes in again and we see oh yeah we
already did that one so here's another
customer experience and I'll do another
vote later if you've seen this so this
is pretty common when you have a mobile
browser and it's so common that Randall
Munroe made it I mean xkcd comic about
this
so to amuse you I'm gonna read that out
for you right now so this is a server
talking and saying hi I'm a server who
are you and we have a mobile phone
answering I'm a browser I'd like to see
this article oh boy I can help let me
get it for whoa
you're a smartphone browser yeah cool
hey I've got this new mobile version of
my site check it out isn't it pretty
sure but this is just your mobile sites
main page version of my site where's the
article I wanted what article the one I
who are you i hi I'm a server so hands
up who see
this before I've seen this before many
times what does this mean it means you
had a customer who is interested in your
product if you're doing business they
can't find your product you lost the
sale you have not very good customer
relationship at this point and you lose
the reputation so you want to avoid that
and what's more in today's world of
viral videos and products being seen all
over movies
something's mentioned on the news you
can have sudden changes in interests in
some of your products what do you want
to have on your main homepage you want
to have the product that most people are
interested in right now right so you
want to have real-time alerting because
this can happen really quickly so what
do we do in stream processing when we
have a challenge like this we want to
count rates of interest per time unit
let's say something's involving sessions
or the session is this 30 minute period
and we want to count some some user
interactions so maybe we have a
windowing counter or windowing average
and we're saying oh yeah after one hour
I can tell you what happened maybe it's
too late maybe all the customers went
straight to your website didn't find
your product they left it's 1 hour 1
hour ago you find out there was this
interest you put the thing there nobody
cares anymore so you want to know a
little bit sooner right so here in this
this example I'm showing a rapid change
in an interest from kind of green
through yellow to red and at the end of
the green interval we're saying oh yeah
everything's green and it's not anymore
so what you want to do is you want to
produce more output you want to let
everybody know what's going on right now
what's happening recently just like you
have some work to do that takes maybe a
month you don't say oh yeah after one
month it's done you say what's my
progress after a few days right so the
same thing here and you can observe your
your current view of the world into some
state and extrapolate what would you
expect to be seeing after that 100 which
is your window and you can trigger your
alarm too early as I hate this there's a
lot of these red things coming in maybe
we should do something about it
and in that case we can push our latency
way down because we before when we wait
for the entire window to close our
latency is way up and of course if we
have a internal state we use a lot of
memory or we use an external state here
so in in total we have to design around
pauses we want low latency and we make
our design decisions accordingly
so even when we do design for low
latency when we have resilient and
distributed applications we will have
some restart pauses that we have to work
through and we're going to have some
ketchup bursts and our data consumers
need to plan with fall back in place to
bridge these pauses and we can carefully
design our streaming applications to
fulfill our business needs for latency
compared to throughput compared to cost
and we can output as a stream to
sophisticated data customers who can
read streams or into a career will state
or into a into a and analytics database
and you've seen internal and external
States for aggregations we talked about
data locality which which can reduce
your latency and we talked about
windowing we're alerting early really
helps to not have to wait for that
window to close which can be a window of
opportunity so for all of this I wrote a
little cheat sheet that we can quickly
go through so stateless our baseline if
we have an internal state then we're
going to use a lot of memory our latency
is going to go a little bit higher
external state we have to talk
to it latency goes up but we don't need
any internal memory anymore if we can
localize our data for example by keying
our data into Kafka we can reduce the
latency back down again if we want to do
exactly once processing that's going to
be very challenging and I have somewhat
higher latency reduce throughput but if
we design with idempotency in mind we
can get that latency down again and
again windowing means we have to wait
for the window to close it's a stateful
process so it's going to consume memory
but if we output all the time we're
going to use a lot of network so that's
going to reduce our foot somewhat but we
can get our latency way way down and
that's that's what we you would want in
some applications right so you have to
choose the right one out of these
options so here's an application so
pretty soon couple ones chatbot ino is
going to roll out the quick reply model
which is essentially a personalized a
number of options that you get from your
chat pod for what you might want to be
doing next and this is based on your
previous interactions as a customer with
us so you don't have to call us you
don't have to ask you don't have to
describe what you're doing you just
interacted with us you just gave us that
information we should know right and so
this is going to be released in waves if
you kept low on customer check your your
app and check your email chat pod this
is one of many applications the call
center application is also something
that's in preparation and many many more
are being worked on which is why we're
hiring engineers data scientists and
technologists so please get in touch or
with with me or with any of our friendly
colleagues for the Capital One t-shirts
we have office hours in room 3 or 2 from
2 o'clock right after this we also have
a booth outside where you can get some
swag so please come see us if you're
interested or
to just chat about stream processing if
you have any other ideas for how to
extend this list be interesting to
thanks very much thank you tell us great
presentation
I was wondering how this is kind of
open-ended maybe outlet scope for this
presentation but I was wondering if you
have any if you if you had to draw if
you had to kind of pick one do you have
a preference towards blank or spark with
some kind of streaming layer wrapped
around it I gave my microphone away so
I'm gonna be back here so there are a
lot of dimensions to this question one
dimension is hiring engineers who are
good with that framework which certainly
is easier for spark at the end of the
day the concepts are the same so it's
not super important as a bullet point
you can learn flink pretty easily as
well spark has some nice convenience
functionality around spark sequel which
makes a few things easy and you can use
the sequel optimizer that'll give you
some pretty nice fast execution for some
things that you might want to be doing
the question about latency is the other
way around
so in that case flink would win blink is
designed with streaming in mind from the
ground up so everything is a stream and
internally hidden from view for you as a
programmer there is some retching going
on just for speed but it happens on the
very short millisecond scale so you
don't really see it as you'll you can
reach the reach levels like 20
millisecond latency
whereas with spark you essentially start
a new spark job with each micro batch
which means you can push the latency
arbitrarily low you can get as low as
maybe 200 milliseconds but
you try to push further and just throw
capacity at the problem you're not going
to get anywhere because of the overhead
of starting these spark jobs for every
micro batch any other questions but
there is a just to just to finish that
there is a there's a spark streaming
engine specifically that was developed
by data bricks that avoids this so they
there is a parallel development I think
it's a plan to be released into open
source spark with some version in the
future
[Music]